madame monsieur bonsoir bienvenue au 20
heures le deuxième grand chassé croisé
des vacanciers a commencé attention si
vous prenez la route ce soir ou demain
vous serez nombreux au plus fort de la
journée on comptait déjà 250 km de
bouchons vacances aussi pour le premier
des français
l'elysée a confirmé tout à l'heure les
vacances américaines de nicolas sarkozy
dans le nord-est du pays à l'invitation
d'amis précise le communiqué vous verrez
que les habitants de la région attendent
avec impatience le président français
dans ce journal nous reparlerons aussi
des dangers des rencontres sur internet
pour les plus jeunes une adolescente de
16 ans a été agressé après avoir accepté
un rendez vous l'homme un récidiviste a
pu être arrêté
les députés veulent en savoir plus sur
les dessous de la négociation entre la
france et la libye le président de
l'assemblée nationale a proposé une
commission d enquête parlementaire et
tout à l'heure le chef de l'état s'y est
dit favorable
enfin rester avec nous jusqu'à la fin de
ce journal pour entendre cette
incroyable histoire l'équipe de football
de manchester vient de recruter le plus
jeune joueur de tous les temps
il a tonné vous bien neuf ans on le voit
ici sur un dvd c'est comme ça qu'il a
été recruté
on commence avec une autre première un
président de la république française en
vacances d'été aux états unis cela aussi
c'est du jamais vu et bien nicolas
sarkozy même pendant les congés semble
vouloir poursuivre sa rupture
il est arrivé tout à l'heure en famille
dans la très chic villégiature de wolf
boro où vous allez le voir il était très
attendu
frédéric rota david fossard wolf boro la
plus ancienne station balnéaire des
états unis l'une des plus chics une des
plus branchés aussi sur son site
internet la municipalité de la ville
souhaite la bienvenue au président
français de venir ici passer ses
vacances
c'est magnifique et nous avons tout ce
qu'il faut pour clara chacun au bord du
lac uni bizot qui à deux heures de route
de boston c'est cette petite ville que
nicolas sarkozy a choisi pour se reposer
en famille walf boro 6000 habitants
possède tous les charmes de la nouvelle
angleterre et a déjà attiré de
nombreuses célébrités
si les gens reconnaissent le président
français il y a tellement personnes
riches et célèbres ici qu'ils ne seront
pas embêter les reporters de la
télévision locale ont découvert que des
membres de l'entourage du président
français était venu manger ici il ya
quelques jours
précision importante
n'ont pas commandé de french touch ne
savons pas encore s'il commandera des
frites mais le président sarkozy est
attendu ici pour dîner les propriétaires
du restaurant affirmé qu'ils seront
ravis lui préparer ce qu'il veut cuisine
française ou non certains habitants ont
cru voir il y a quelques jours des
membres des services secrets français
patrouiller sur ce lac notamment autour
de cette maison lieu de villégiature de
nicolas sarkozy dont les images
promotionnelles circulent sur internet
gigantesque bâtisse de 1200 m²
appartenant à un ancien patron de
microsoft nike est ici en short blanc
tarifs de location de ce havre de paix
pour une semaine 22000 euros
on ignore pour l'instant si le président
a loué ou non cet endroit de rêve
seule précision de l'elysée il est
invité par des amis
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il ne
rencontrera ici aucune hostilité
bien au contraire le comité d'accueil a
fait un petit effort linguistique et
pour la majorité de ceux qui débutent
leurs vacances aujourd'hui voilà à quoi
elle ressemble pour l'heure des
embouteillages beaucoup d'embouteillages
images ici de l'embranchement entre
l'a10 et l'a6 tourné il ya quelques
minutes au plus fort de la journée à
17h30 on comptait jusqu'à 2500 le pardon
de 150 c'est suffisant de 150 km de
bouchons sur tout le réseau routier
français et depuis ils ont commencé à se
résorber voici maintenant la carte du
trafic routier en temps réel vous le
voyez les bouchons dont nous parlions
concernent pour l'heure essentiellement
l'a7 au sud de lyon l'a9 vers l'espagne
un petit peu aussi de bouchons au pays
basque
et puis bien sûr l'adisq avec des
difficultés pour l'instant qui semble se
concentrer autour de tours et poitiers
enfin ce qui concerne la journée de
demain voyez les prévisions de bison
futé la journée s'annonce carrément noir
cette fois-ci conseil du bison attendait
dimanche pour partir si vous en avez
bien sûr la possibilité
alors pour votre sécurité pour celle des
autres sachez que les gendarmes seront
particulièrement vigilants ce week-end
dès aujourd'hui les contrôles se sont
multipliés
la vitesse est bien entendu surveiller
mais aussi tous les autres types
d'infractions que l'on peut constater
lors des grands départs
reportage dans l'oise sur l'a1 arnault
compte david fossard 131 km heure au
lieu des 110 autorisés dans cette
descente de motards crs lance
l'interception 5 kilomètres plus loin
le contrevenant est arrêté il s'agit
d'un automobiliste néerlandais
si j'avais vu le panneau de limitation
j'aurais ralenti mais je ne les ai pas
vus pour cette étourderie
ce sera 90 euros il aura qu'une amende
de la payer sur place mais pourquoi
c'est une personne étrangère n'ont pas
de formation perdu sur ce secteur de
l'autoroute a1 en 3h08 sans excès de
vitesse ont été relevées 20 kilomètres
en amont la gare de péage de chamant 30
crs sont déployés ici contrôle de
papiers mais aussi peu épais conduisant
il ya 200 kg de thon transporter autre
chose tant sur quoi vous n'avez pas
l'impression de prendre des risques en
conduisant
assange aura 90 soit plus 103-90 les
risques même sur les vides des risques y
aura toujours des résidences pour
repartir
il faut alléger le véhicule est sacrifié
des effets personnels a dit que j'étais
avant comment ils étaient en infraction
pour lui a pris c'est sont ses affaires
et les affaires sont détruites les
affaires sont détruites
ce week-end pour ce deuxième grand
chassé croisé de l'été 21 mille
fonctionnaires de police sont mobilisés
sur tout le territoire
mais dès ce soir beaucoup de voyageurs
sont aussi attendus dans les aéroports
plus de 800000 personnes devraient
passer par orly et paris roissy
d'ici à dimanche la situation sera aussi
chargé dans les grands aéroports
régionaux
reportage dans celui de bâle mulhouse où
l'on attend une hausse de fréquentation
de plus de 50% par rapport à un week-end
normal
stéphanie la fuente mathieu benito c'est
l'heure où les impatients aoûtiens par
enfin tandis que les derniers
juillettistes un peu en retard prennent
le chemin du retour et remballent leurs
affaires comme ce couple de hollandais
après un périple à vélo entre suisse et
italie dans une heure il s'envole pour
amsterdam
soir info morbach c'est toujours plus
difficile de rentrer à la maison
surtout quand les vacances sont épais
belle madrid
heraklion lanzarote les destinations
soleil affiche complet et aux portes
d'embarquement certains vacanciers sont
comme dans des starting blocks
après des mois de travail on est content
de partir en vacances
destination olbia en sardaigne
c'est l'heure du départ le grand départ
attendu avec beaucoup d'impatience
l'air de rien maillots de bain et
serviette de plage prennent de la place
depuis 4h30 ce matin les valises
défilent sur le tapis de tri pour les
bagagistes les week-ends de départs sont
un véritable exercice de force on peut
faire pour une matinée qui est bien
chargé à peu près jusqu'à 100 tonnes de
bagages par matinée ça fait à peu près
10 tonnes de bagages par personne au
total soixante mille passagers sont
attendus et sur le tarmac 250 décollage
autant d'atterrissage soit 40 % de vols
en plus et pourtant ces dernières années
les vols charters sont moins nombreux
c'est clair ça a diminué à cause de
l'effet du low cost ou des vols low cost
qui ont repris une partie des vols
charters dernier rush prévue la semaine
prochaine car l'euroairport est
binational est pour nos voisins suisses
le 15 août c'est déjà la fin des grandes
vacances et enfin côté train maintenant
une image celle de la gare de lyon il y
à quelques minutes vous le voyez la
situation est encore plutôt calme c'est
le train-train de l'avant chassés
croisés si l'on peut dire
la sncf attend tout de même 3 million et
demi de voyageurs dans les deux sens ce
week-end pas moins de 1768 g20 ont
d'ailleurs été mis à leur disposition
espérons pour eux qu'ils auront plus de
chance que les passagers de la navette
eurotunnel aujourd'hui deux d'entre
elles en provenance d'angleterre sont
restés bloqués plus de quatre heures
sous la manche et quatre heures dans un
tunnel sous la mer c'est quand même long
en cause d'une rupture d'alimentation
électrique
l'ugb haziza
sur des kilomètres côté anglais un
embouteillage à l'entrée dû tunnel sous
la manche est de trop longues heures à
patienter jusqu'à 5 heures d'attentes
pour le fret et trois heures pour les
passagers mieux valait ne pas être
claustrophobe en montant à bord des
navettes ferroviaires ce matin les
voyageurs en provenance de folkestone
sont restés bloqués sous la mer bien
malgré eux à 10h30 une première navette
s'immobilise suite à l'interruption de
l'alimentation d'une caténaire
immédiatement véhicules de pompiers
personnels d'eurotunnel arrivent sur
place par le tunnel de service
il s'assure alors de la sécurité des
personnes présentes et des boissons sont
distribués au bout de deux heures une
deuxième navette immobilisé en amont
airs et aiguiller vers l'autre tunnel
ferroviaire habituellement utilisés en
sens inverse
le premier train est finalement tracté
par une locomotive diesel vers la sortie
en france située à tout juste 5 km après
4 heures d'immobilisation
ce soir les réparations sont terminées
les retards restent inférieures à une
demi heure
finalement après de longues heures
d'attentes la route des vacances s'ouvre
enfin
alors en dehors de ces impondérables qui
par définition ne peuvent pas se prévoir
comment justement bien préparer ses
vacances
et bien certains pensent qu'il faut s'y
prendre à l'avancé en revanche et c'est
nouveau d'autres s'y prennent paraître
dernière minute sur internet pour faire
des affaires
vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux à
procéder ainsi mais est ce vraiment une
bonne idée
on voit ça avec marion pile as et
olivier ponthus ce hier encore ce jeune
couple ne savait pas qu'il allait partir
en vacances ce soir ils sont dans les
caraïbes
leur séjour ils ont réservé sur un coup
de tête il ya de la place
sans se mettre de pression quand on
choisit un départ à l'avance on est
obligé de partir là où on l'avait décidé
il ya
un maillot de bain un hamac et le tour
est joué l'année dernière un tiers des
vacanciers ont choisi leur séjour au
dernier moment le paradis à portée de
main vous si vous en rêvez et bien bon
courage dans cette agence de voyages
tout est quasiment vendu cet été pour
partir ce week-end ou même la semaine
prochaine il vaut mieux ne pas être trop
difficile et les dates qu'on souhaite
sartre ou pas et le tarif est la
destination c'est vraiment petit bonheur
la chance parce qu'ea disponible ci à
l'éducation le 10 août geda place mais
plus pour l'appartement casa del sol
inutile de vous rabattre sur les tours
opérateurs en ligne c'est le même
casse-tête bien défini c'est exactement
après 500 600 euros les promotions sont
partis depuis longtemps
résultat personne qui avait un budget de
600 euros 700 euros elle vient dépenser
2478 en août ces zooms les dernières
minutes coûte deux fois plus cher que le
reste de l'année
un moyen pour les tours opérators de
compenser les pertes des mois creux le
monde nous vendions les périodes les
plus demandées à un prix beaucoup plus
élevés ce qui fait un prix moyen normal
jusqu'à 1500 euros pour 9 jours de
croisière en mer caraïbe pour beaucoup
cet été ces belles images resteront sur
papier glacé lui aussi voulait payer
moins cher un pompiste du var a eu
l'incroyable idée de mélanger du diesel
avec du kérosène autrement dit du
carburant pour avions autant dire que
les moteurs de voiture n'apprécie guère
mais cette arnaque lui permettait de
payer moins de taxes à la durée deux ans
j ai terrain
ici on vous servait le cocktail maison
six volumes de gazole pour 4 de kérosène
et comme le kérosène est moins taxé que
le gazole
les prix à la pompe était imbattable
trop beau pour être honnête on avait des
doutes qui mettait dechirot zem dedans
mais bon
à quoi vous aviez des doutes des doutes
de soupçons il y avait les ondes y est
il est point il se cachait pas trop pour
transférer le
le gasoil dans la citerne quoi vous
l'avez vu faire du transvasement oui
bien sûr la technique était simple
plusieurs fois par semaine le patron de
la station service retrouvé un des
livres de l'aéroport de nice le kérosène
passait d'un véhicule à l'autre
en deux ans ce petit camion citerne
aurait détourné plus d'un million de
litres de carburant la tentation existe
un peu où elle est le carburant faux pas
est ce que c'est une fraude courante
dans le métier
bref pop fatalement ici si ça profite
pas pour mais bon sur marseille c'est
sûr il ya eu des gros trafic sur
marseille le pompiste indélicat a été
placé en détention provisoire
il risque trois ans de prison ferme et
les douanes lui réclament plus de 600000
euros de taxes impayées
un incendie s'est déclaré tout à l'heure
près de narbonne 120 sapeurs pompiers
sont actuellement mobilisés ils n'ont
toujours pas réussi à maîtriser les
flammes et déjà quelque 70 hectares de
garrigue sont partis en fumée sur place
jenny briffa annie tri boire poussé par
le vent le feu progresse vite en une
heure à peine
il s'est propagé de la garrigue vers le
quartier des hauts de narbonne
en tout 70 hectares ont brûlé en fasse
un petit cabanon brûle mais ça arrive
paris 6 à savoir moins dangereux parce
que y'a tout mais très coûteux fait il
ya quelque chose qui a sauté dans la
maison
dès le départ du feu vers 15 heures
quatre canadair deux tracker sont
mobilisés il évolue au milieu des lignes
haute tension au sol 130 pompiers
s'activent pour protéger la zone
industrielle de narbonne croix du sud
les moyens sont atteints convergé vers
la pointe du feu ainsi que les moyens
aériens qui ont un temps de faire une
attaque massive sur les fleurs est plus
virulent du feu on espère pouvoir
maintenir la pression
la progression afin qu'ils arrivent sur
la zone ici mais vers 18 heures la zone
industrielle a quand même dû être
évacuées
ce soir les zones d'habitation sont hors
de danger mais les pompiers restent
mobilisés pour fixer le feu
encore une histoire qui rappelle
qu'internet peut aussi être dangereux
pour les plus jeunes un homme de 43 ans
vient d'être écroué pour agression
sexuelle
il utilisait un service de messagerie
pour attirer ses proies séduite par sa
conversation une adolescente de 16 ans
est tombé dans le piège elle pensait
avoir affaire à un garçon de son âge
renaud bernard philippe chaix cela après
des semaines de conversations sur
internet le pédophile est parvenu à
tirer sa proie jusqu'ici en gare de
poitiers
persuadé de rencontrer michael un jeune
gendarme de 19 ans l'adolescente est
arrivé confiante
le pédophile un quadragénaire a réussi
ensuite à retenir la jeune fille durant
trois jours dans une chambre d'hôtel
avant qu'elle donne l'alertent elle a eu
du mal à réaliser
en fait qu'elle était entre les mains
d'un prédateur que l'on peut qualifier
de psychologiquement dangereux par
rapport aux atteintes sexuelles qu'il
envisage est pratiqué sur la jeune fille
l'usurpation d'identité c'est le mode
opératoire des pédophiles sur internet
en france une association se bat contre
ça elle a organisé une campagne de
publicité l'hiver dernier
un pseudo pu cacher n'importe qui ne
donnez jamais votre nom votre adresse ou
votre télé n'acceptez jamais de rendez
vous sans être coupés action innocence
se bat sur tous les fronts pour protéger
les enfants contre les pédophiles
pour responsabiliser les parents aussi
au contenu
il est des outils de contrôle parental
gestion des applications utilisées ou d
or et de correction d'autant que sur la
toile les prédateurs sont de plus en
plus nombreux comme ici un homme d'âge
mûr qui se fait appeler fleur de lotus
saisi cet après midi par les gendarmes
en pleine conversation sur un forum avec
une adolescente de 11 ans un logement
sur deux est équipé d'une connexion
internet
donc ça permet aux prédateurs qui ont
des fois des difficultés à aborder
physiquement quelqu'un ne fait pas de se
faire passer pour une personne aux
autres et de trouver la personne qui
aura des difficultés au sein de sa
famille ou psychologiquement pour le
moment les gendarmes ne lutte pas à
armes égales contre les pédophiles pour
les piéger ils ne peuvent pas se faire
passer pour des mineurs
une loi votée au printemps dernier les y
autorise pourtant mais son décret
d'application n'a toujours pas été signé
certains députés voulaient en savoir
plus il devrait donc y avoir une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire sur
les dessous de la négociation entre la
france et la libye
l'idée de cette commission était
proposée par le président de l'assemblée
nationale bernard accoyer le président
de la république nicolas sarkozy s'y est
dit favorable tout à l'heure ils
souhaitent ainsi prouver que le contrat
d'armement signés entre la france et la
libye n'est pas une contrepartie de la
libération des infirmières bulgares
thierry curtet dominique bonnet patrice
trop cher
les infirmières bulgares enfin libre les
contrats militaires enfin signé
coïncidence ou corrélation car si ce
sont les sociétés privées qui vendent
les armes
rien ne peut exporter sans c1
gouvernementale la noce par tripoli de
l'achat de missiles milan pour 168
millions d'euros oblige le gouvernement
français à s'expliquer ce contrat
discuté depuis deux ans a reçu le feu
vert de la commission spéciale chargée
des exportations en février dernier par
cette précision le ministre de la
défense entend démontrer que ce contrat
n'est pas liée à la libération des
soignants bulgares et les choses se sont
faites en février 2007 c'est-à-dire bien
avant la question de la libération des
infirmières bulgares
d'ailleurs le personnel de eads était
depuis plusieurs dizaines de jours en
libye pour finaliser cet accord ce qui
est vrai c'est que la présence du
président de la république en libye au
moment de la conclusion d'un tel accord
facilite toujours les choses jusqu'à
quel point la visite de nicolas sarkozy
en libye at elle facilité les choses
c'est ce que veut savoir aujourd'hui
l'opposition
perturbé par le fait que les
informations ne viennent sur ce dossier
que de tripoli le ps demande une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire
si on pense qu'il n'y a rien à cacher
alors faisons leclerc et comme cette
commission d' enquête comporte tous les
partis politiques
eh bien toutes les informations seront
données toutes les suspicions je
l'espère seront levés mais restera une
question est ce qu'on doit fournir des
armes au régime du colonel kadhafi ce
soir l'elysée veut donner l'impression
de jouer la transparence nicolas sarkozy
se dit donc favorable à une telle
commission d' enquête en grande-bretagne
est l'un des auteurs de l'attentât
manqué contre l'aéroport de glasgow est
mort la nuit dernière des suites de ses
blessures il était âgé de 27 ans et se
trouvaient à bord de la jeep bourré
d'essence qui avait été projetée contre
l'entrée de l'aéroport c'était le 30
juin dernier dans la bataille pour le
contrôle des réserves énergétiques du
pôle nord rien n'arrête la russie on
vous en a parlé hier voyez ce soir
l'image celle du drapeau russe plantés
dans les fonds marins de l'arctique pur
spectacle ironisait hier le canada mais
aujourd'hui le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères s'est dit choqué par
cette réaction
le drapeau est en titane at il précisé
celui que vous avez vu précédemment
autrement dit aussi solide que la
volonté russe de mettre la main sur les
ressources des fonds marins du pôle nord
rien ne va plus pour la poupée
exploratrice doha si vous avez une
petite fille à la maison vous voyez de
quoi il s'agit le géant américain du
jouet fisher price a décidé de rappeler
un million de modèles
motif ils pourraient contenir des
peintures toxiques à base de plomb les
lots incriminés ont été fabriqués en
chine et plus de 500 pièces auraient été
vendus en france frédéric manca et
frédéric de larges ailes à un château
des amis un camion de bonnes ventes
dora l'exploratrice a tout pour plaire
sauf sa peinture
elles présentent des teneurs en plomb
anormales sur certains jouets fabriqués
en chine le groupe américain mattel a
donc décidé de retirer un million et
demi de jouer à travers le monde en
france 570 produits sont concernés
il s'agit du camping-car bilingue du
coffret partons à l'aventuré et du tube
de trois figurines dans tous les cas il
faut vérifier le numéro de fabrication
les produits concernés sont les numéros
de lots 109,7 l f 117 élèves ça en doses
ainsi de suite jusqu'à 187 7 élèves
si vous avez un doute une question vous
pouvez appeler un numéro vert le 0 800 5
800 248
aux états unis où ces jouets sont
particulièrement populaires
l' affaire suscite l'indignation
certains n'hésitent pas à accuser les
chinois d'avoir utilisé du plomb pour
réduire leurs coûts de production
inimaginable dit on à pékin il nous
demande de fabriquer des jouets nous
respectons les mêmes normes de qualité
que les normes internationales ils
viennent ici surtout parce que les coûts
de production sont plus bas que chez eux
mais les américains doutent de ce genre
de discours car la chine leur a déjà
vendu du dentifrice à l'antigel de la
nourriture pour chiens et chats mortel
pour des milliers d'animaux
ces scandales alimentent une vaste
guerre commerciale et un débat sans fin
sur la délocalisation
tout le monde les connaît sous le nom de
plantons mais dans la gendarmerie on les
appelle des gardes statiques le ministre
de la défense souhaite supprimer 500
postes pour dit-il recentrer les
gendarmes sur leur coeur de métier c'est
son expression
il faut dire que gardes statiques pour
un gendarme mobile ce n'est pas
forcément évident accepté john irish
times thomas donzel
dans le jargon policier on appelle ça
faire du bitume ou encore jouer les
plantes vertes
rien qu'à paris deux mille cinq cents
gendarmes et gardiens de la paix sur v
ainsi toute la journée
assemblée nationale ministères et
ambassades
un gendarme ou un policier sans
trottoirs d'une porte cochère croyez-moi
premièrement c'est pas un travail c'est
particulièrement intéressant de deux
soleils sont certainement pas rentrer ni
dans la police ni à la gendarmerie pour
faire le planton
et puis de trois salles abritent une
utilité aujourd'hui le ministre de la
défense hervé morin souhaite supprimer
500 plants ont dans la gendarmerie pour
les réaffecter à des missions jugé plus
utile
premier concerné le château de bity et
ses 37 gendarmes d'année d'ici à 12 mois
s'est résidence privée de jacques chirac
ne devrait plus être protégés par les
militaires hervé morin a également fait
le ménage chez lui au ministère de la
défense début juillet 23 postes ont été
supprimés à la place des caméras et des
vigiles privés pourraient être installés
il faut regarder c'est qu'est ce qui est
le mieux au meilleur prix par rapport à
la mission qui est exercée courir après
les voleurs c'est une mission de la
police et de la gendarmerie faire
l'accueil et l'orientation ce une
mission pour des hôtesses
en disant gendarmerie et police se sont
débarrassés de contraintes comme
l'entretien des véhicules ou le
nettoyage des locaux
elle voudrait également que le transfert
des prisonniers soient confiées aux
gardiens de prison dans le sud ouest
elles sont incontournables l'été les
fêtes de bayonne ont commencé elles
doivent rassembler jusqu'à dimanche près
d'un million trois cent mille personnes
la plupart viennent pour s'amuser mais
l'alcool aidant la violence aussi est
souvent au rendez vous sur place jean
françois feer et marine vincent
ils sont des centaines adolescents ou
jeunes adultes à déambuler chaque soir
des fêtes de bayonne l'alcool à portée
de la main en plus profitable plus
grande
en fait il se fait appeler sur le petit
bouton comme ceci
content pour eux la boisson fait partie
intégrante de la fête
quitte à frôler avec le danger et
exemple mercredi soir deux garçons ivre
danse sur les remparts et tombe il se
blesse assez sérieusement
en deux jours les 500 policiers et crs
ont interpellé une trentaine de
personnes essentiellement pour des
violences dues à l'alcool des
débordements qui défigurent le vrai
visage de la fête une fête en rouge et
blanc aux couleurs de pampelune la vie
qui inspirait ces festivités à bayonne
le basque danse dans les rues de la cité
depuis 1932 même tout petit on s'y met
d'ailleurs selon la légende un basque
apprend c'est pas 2 2 avant même de
savoir parler
la tradition de force et qui dit
folklore à bayonne dit vachette
mais la demoiselle a du tempérament les
ringards elle les écorne le basque lui a
sa propre technique de drague seul peu
dangereux mais bon suffit d'être du pays
et de colère des gens mais n'en avait
que lui tu sais pas vos clics est un
petit bijou à la vache normalement elle
vous leur a pas de problème mais qui
donc pour bâillonner le bâillonner car
le soir le revoilà cette fois avec une
banda une quarantaine de ces groupes
locaux et sème le parcours de peignant
peña en basque une peña
c'est un bar associatif d'ordinaire
réservé aux initiés mais pendant les
fêtes ont fait quelques exceptions
différents officiels et franchement un
million trois cent mille testèrent ne se
tairont une bonne fois pour toutes que
dimanche soir il sera alors temps de
retirer le foulard surtout pas vrai on
va rêver un peu maintenant avec la
nouvelle tendance pour les piscines
là encore le label écolo est devenu à la
mode plus question du bleu turquoise et
des produits chimiques
l'heure est au bassin auto nettoyé par
de vrais algues en fait vous allez le
voir cela ressemble plus à un étang qu'à
une piscine c'est beau mais encore plus
cher
reportage dans les alpes maritimes
franck jen aux offres et drake apprend
au pied de saint paul de vence
il existe un petit coin de paradis diack
dans ce gîte touristique une piscine
sans ajout de produits chimiques 100%
naturel c'est super y'a pas de chlore
alors ça pique pas du tout les yeux
le concept vient de suisse l'idée est de
reconstituer un environnement naturel la
piscine est en fait composé de deux
bassins
dans un premier bassin une grille
aspirent les dépôts comme les feuilles
ou les cheveux il passe alors dans un
deuxième bassin rempli de roches
volcaniques ou des bactéries les
transforme en matière minérale absorbée
par les plantes d'eau dernière nécessité
une cascade ou un jet d'eau pour
alimenter les bactéries en oxygène plus
besoin d'entretenir votre piscine
la nature le fait pour qu'on quelques ce
qui se fait ce que fait la nature a une
toute petite échelle et on va créer un
biotope un biotope naturel dans lequel
vient de s'installer toute la faune
naturellement n'apporte absolument rien
en faune uniquement les plantes et des
matériaux minéraux la formule séduit des
clients plutôt aisée il y en aurait déjà
plusieurs centaines en france prix
minimum cinquante mille euros c'est en
moyenne deux fois plus qu'une piscine
traditionnelle jacques n'aurait lui a
vite choisi ce retraité ne voulait pas
voir ce qu'il appelle une tâche
turquoise sur son terrain bordé
d'olivier tricentenaire s'y retrouver
leur enfance j'ai eu la chance d'être un
peu plus jeunes baigner dans les
rivières équilibres naturels est garanti
à vie par les fabricants
désormais vous pourrez vous permettre
d'ouvrir les yeux soul chose promise
chose due voici maintenant l'incroyable
histoire d'un jeune prodige du football
il faut croire en tout cas que c'en est
un puisque le célèbre club de manchester
united vient de le recruter alors qu'il
n'a que neuf ans pas question pour
l'heure bien sûr de le faire jouer avec
les grands mais s'il poursuit sur sa
lancée le club anglais préfèrent le
garder à portée de main correspondance
claude saint père il s'appelle one davis
il a 9 ans et je joue déjà au football
comme un professionnel
sur ces images on le voit évoluer dans
cette petite équipe dans la banlieue de
brisbane en australie
son grand père vient d'envoyer un dvd
avec ces images aux dirigeants de la
prestigieuse équipe de manchester united
en angleterre
la décision n'a pas traîné ils ont
décidé de l'engager
lauren davis aura peut-être un jour la
chance de fouler la célèbre pelouse
d'old trafford
pour l'heure les dirigeants ont décidé
de le faire venir en angleterre avec son
père et dès la rentrée le petit prodige
jouera dans l'équipe des diables rouges
l'équipe des moins de 12 ans la presse
anglaise le compare déjà à ronaldo un
des joueurs vedettes de l'équipe même
toucher de balle même aptitude à faire
des dribbles incroyables tout jeunes
rêvent de devenir des grands joueurs ce
n'est tous n'en sont pas capables
il faut juste jouer pour le plaisir
juste les images de ronaldinho gamins
jouant au foot on fait le tour du monde
la presse anglaise adore ces histoires
de jeunes prodiges
il y a quelques mois les télévisions
diffusaient déjà les images de ce tout
jeune joueur charli edwards trois ans
pas encore l'âge d'aller à l'école
mais un bon coup de pied et déjà selon
les spécialistes de réelles qualités
footballistiques
alors retenez bien le nom de notre petit
prodige australien il s'appelle rennes
davis et les bookmakers anglais ont déjà
ouvert les paris pour savoir s'il
deviendra bien un jour
une superstar du football et ce n'est
pas la grande forme en revanche pour nos
champions à nous on peut même dire que
la coupe est pleine pour le sextuple
champion de france le club lyonnais
cumule depuis quelques mois les coups
durs si bien que l'on se demande même
s'il pourra tenir son rang cette saison
romain mais si olivier jacque l'art un
genou qui lâche et une saison pas encore
commencé déjà gâchée grégory coupet
blessé à l'entraînement hier mâtin sera
absent des terrains quatre mois un coup
dur mais pas un coup au moral
très sincèrement avec la figure j'ai
fait je m'attendais vraiment à ce que le
l'addition soit beaucoup plus sévère
voilà moi moi je suis sur la touche
maintenant donc il n'ya pas de question
de penser un gréco couper couper les
routes menant à un gardien en moins et
une mauvaise nouvelle de plus pour l'ol
derrière le calme apparent de
l'entraînement jamais le despote de la
ligue 1 a connu un été aussi mouvementé
champions pour la sixième fois d'affilée
en mai lyon n'a pas réussi à retenir ses
meilleurs joueurs partis pour trouver
mieux ailleurs
malouda transféré à chelsea pour 20
millions d'euros
abidal à barcelone pour 15 millions 8 et
le portugais tiago à turin pour 13
millions lyon a les poches pleines mais
des talents en moins
pour voir ces joueurs qui viennent
d'arriver c'est au niveau de la ligue
des champions je sais pas si vous êtes
champions décidée à garder son trône en
ligue 1 lyon a fait l'économie d'un
recrutement à paillettes pas de vedettes
mais de bons joueurs de clubs français
un nouvel entraîneur reconnu mais
discret et une seule star l'italien
fabio grosso l'homme du dernier tir au
but face à la france en finale de la
coupe du monde
suffisant peut-être pour la ligue 1 pas
forcément pour affronter l'europe
certains y voient déjà les prémices du
déclin je pense que ce sont les gens qui
connaissent pas le football et il
devrait apprendre à être plus prudents
parce qu'ils se sont déjà les mêmes
souvent trompé dans les années
précédentes nous nous pensons que
l'équipe est au moins aussi forte que
celle de l'année dernière à voir mais
pour son premier match officiel de la
saison l'ol a tout fait comme d'habitude
victoire contre sochaux 2-1 le week-end
dernier et les lyonnais remporte un
sixième trophée des champions une
certitude de leur point de vue cette
année
rien ne va changer
et toujours en football il faudra que
les toulousains soit en grande forme
pour se qualifier pour la ligue des
champions le tirage au sort aujourd'hui
leur a donné comme adversaire le roc de
table équipe de liverpool pour le
troisième tour des préliminaires sport
encore laure manaudou a remporté tout à
l'heure la finale du 100 m dos de l'open
de paris mais surprise vous allez voir
qu'elle n'était pas seule sur la ligne
d'arrivée
elle a terminé ex-aequo avec
l'ukrainienne irina amce nicobar l on
est exactement le même temps au centième
près avec une minute une seconde et 46
centièmes précisément voilà la ligne
d'arrivée et puis on envie aux sports
pour tous maintenant le ski nautique a
longtemps été une discipline très
réservée et bien s'ouvre de plus en plus
y compris aux plus petits après le baby
ski l'hiver voici le baby ski nautique
pour l'été reportage à roquebrune sur
argens dans le var où une école propose
même une initiation gratuite pour les
enfants
renaud bernard allain du bar et si
c'était toi qui commençait dans un
instant valentine va vivre sa première
expérience de ski nautique eu une
première sans effort du haut de ses 5
ans la petite fille semble aussi à
l'aise sur le plan d'eau ils vont jour
là bas que l'équipe de france qui s'y
entraînent d'habitude ça y est
valentine est mort du comment
le baby ski c'est une invention de la
fédération française de ski nautique
la méthode permet d'initier les enfants
de 4 à 7 ans pas besoin de savoir nager
pas d'appréhension en groupe mais voyez
c'est 100 % de réussite pour
démocratiser un sport qui ne l'est pas
toujours
la fédération française de ski nautique
organise tout l'été des journées
d'initiation gratuite sur le ponton les
mamans sont pierre les futurs athlètes
sont ravis je pense que ça lui plaît oui
à la lgv au sourire et ses coûts donc je
pense que ça lui plaît oui il existe
encore peut-être cette image de ski
nautique ou ans parce qu'il faut avoir
son propre bateau pour pratiquer ce qui
n'est pas le cas et c'est justement les
journées portes ouvertes et le baby ski
qui vont lutter contre cette image en
france on compte environ 200 mille
adeptes du ski nautique avec le baby ski
vingt mille jeunes skieurs de plus sont
attendus sur les plans d'eau et on va
faire un peu plaisir un autre oui
maintenant pour terminer la station
verbier célèbre pour son ski l'hiver
reste très chic en été avec ses concerts
de piano les plus grands solistes
viennent s'y produire mais cette année
le festival a décidé de se démocratiser
grâce à internet
isabelle bechler guillaume biard les
plus grands solistes du moment comme
martha argerich c'est la marque de
fabrique du festival de verdi
et
un festival qui a décidé de jouer de
toutes les nouvelles technologies pour
gagner une audience plus large
les concerts sont visibles en direct sur
internet
prokofiev concerto numéro 3
il sera ce un long voyage à travers des
films dans le monde entier sur des
serveurs informatiques et il y a une à
deux secondes de décalage entre le
touché de martha argerich et
l'internaute qui se trouve au chili en
chine ou à quelques kilomètres d'ici
plus besoin donc d'appartenir à la jet
set pour vibrer au rythme fou d'emma de
la folie et apprécier la foule de martha
argerich vous trouvez cette énergie en
énergie du fou je sais pas ça existe un
espagnol c'est expression mais pas en
français l'énergie qui n'est pas une
vraie chance une chose comme ça
peut-être est-ce une vertu de la
montagne les 1500 mètres d'altitude de
la station font peser un peu plus lourd
le violoncelle sur le dos des
instruments tous les deux aussi des dell
havel 18 ans vient de nouveau si bing
pour six courts avec des solistes de
premier plan
l'enseignement c'est des graines que
l'on plante mais qui se développe rend
beaucoup plus tard et quelque part ce
qu'on leur dit aujourd'hui même dans un
master class courte va rejaillir dans
leur propre jeu jusqu'à ce qu'elles
s'intègrent à non content de s'ouvrir à
internet le festival de verbier a
également invité des virtuoses de plus
loin comme anouchka la fille de ravi
shankar
parce que la musique classique
européenne n'a pas le monopole de la
tradition et de la qualité fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi tout de
suite cela météo isabelle martinez suivi
du point route avec julien pascal c'est
important aujourd'hui à 20h50 patrick
sébastien vous fera revivre les années
bonheur et puis quand à moi j'aurai le
bonheur de vous retrouver demain c'est
13 heures excellente soirée sur france 2